RETO MEIER: Hi.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
This is your update on
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
Android 9 Pie, the latest
release of Android,
is now available.
The source code is posted to
Android open source project.
And we're starting
the Android 9 roll out
to all Pixel users
worldwide, with Android 9
coming to many more devices
in the coming months.
For lots of detail on what's
in the release and to get
started enhancing your
app with Android 9
features and APIs, head
on over to the post
linked in the description below.
We recently released the
Chrome UX Report Dashboard
to help you better
understand how an origin's
performance evolves.
It's built on Data Studio
and automatically syncs
with the latest datasets and can
be easily customized and shared
with everyone on your team.
For screenshots and a
video on how to set it up,
take a look at the post.
The stable release of
Dart 2 is now available,
including a rewrite of
the Dart web platform that
offers a unique combination
of productivity, performance,
and scalability.
To learn more about Dart
2 and for links to get
started with Flutter and
the Dart web toolset,
head on over to the post.
Second Generation App
Engine standard runtimes
are now available.
It's a significant upgrade
to the platform that
allows you to easily
run web apps using up
to date versions of popular
languages, frameworks,
and libraries.
Python 3.7 is available today in
beta on the App Engine Standard
Environment.
Spring Cloud GCP is a project
in the Spring Cloud family
that helps Java developers build
Spring Boot applications that
consume Google Cloud
Platform services easily
and idiomatically.
And it's now
generally available.
You can learn more on the
post linked in the description
below.
And you can now back up and
replay your streaming pipeline
events using Cloud Pub/Sub,
Cloud Storage, and Cloud Data
Flow, all directly
from the Cloud
console via a new collection of
simple import/export templates.
Screenshots and details on
how it works are on the post.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Reto Meier for
"The Developer Show."
Thanks for watching, and
we'll see you next week.
This is good pie.